earlier we introduced you to mom of two
maria cook
and after losing her father to covid19
she dedicated her knights to helping
at-risk seniors
secure appointments for the covet 19
vaccine
and the people she's helped have
referred to her
as a vaccine angel and her kids had
taken over her living room
as most kids do and we wanted to help
her reclaim her space we thought who is
more deserving than maria so we sent in
our team to take care of everything and
they cleared out all the toys
and we painted the walls and we brought
in brand new furniture
and our good friend and design expert
mikhail
welch joined us for the big reveal
because we had
taken care of every detail so he's there
in person
to show it all take a look
[Music]
oh my god oh my god
this is fantastic oh my god hi oh my god
you're in my mouth
how does it look oh my god
oh is that the couch that i
looked at with drew that is absolutely
the couch that you looked at with you
oh god i always wanted one of these oh
my gosh i always wanted one of these
i wish my dad was here what do you think
this would mean to your father if you
were here right now
when we first bought this house
my dad would come and paint her garage
so he could
be part of all of this right
he would be ecstatic he would be
i just i have no words i just i can't
i can't describe how fantastic this room
is
unrecognizable i think you know your
father is here with us right now
and definitely his spirit will be with
you here
and i'm going to tell you the truth
maria drew gave us a really big job and
we had to knock it out of the park so
let's just talk about the overall design
because as you can see
it's drastically different it's amazing
well we wanted to keep things kind of
light and airy right with those kind of
monochromatic neutral tones
and so the wall color is something
actually called city loft
now take a look at the doors right
behind you
we've painted them tricorn which is
essentially like a really
rich black and when we work with these
neutral colors we need a little pop so
we went with like
caramel tones like when you look at the
leather stools here take a seat here
oh man yeah sit down and enjoy it do you
see how deep this is
think about family movie night or really
you can have like
daytime dates and you can watch drew's
show every day i'm thinking about
napping
so we had a little situation with the
toys
i had to donate them um i'm joking oh my
god
but can you guess where the toys are in
the room
go ahead and take a seat on your bench
oh yes please honey that was your clue
oh really oh sorry
oh my god this was the
biggest thing that drew told us most
importantly she wanted
a storage bench right in front of the
bay window
take a look up under that bench it's not
the same color
as the city loft that color down on the
bottom
of that bench is actually alpaca
so oh we paired like a a super
bright white with like a more subdued
version of it
and the two of them just work like
harmoniously
look at the space right it's very serene
wouldn't you say
yeah i want to sit here and have tea
it's because look around
we didn't add any ceiling lights we have
lots of
ambient light i'm kind of jealous of you
right this is i
i am jealous of myself right now
this is amazing like i cannot thank you
enough for even doing that i can't even
believe that you're here
no listen and what you do for the
community as a whole
and having gone through what you went
through with your father i think at the
least this is what is owed to you at the
end of the day all i want is for my
dad's legacy to continue
thank you to drew for even having me in
her mind
you know i'm sure she's busy as well and
i just i cannot thank you enough that
this is beyond what i thought that
was going to happen this is amazing
well i am so happy that maria got the
amazing new space that she deserves
and guess what she's here joining us
from her fabulous new living room
hi maria how are you
i am so good i'm so happy to see you
what do you think i'm in love it's
fantastic it's a great space and i
cannot thank you enough for this
well i just really appreciate your
journey
um i am so sorry for your loss with your
father
but to me you are the marker of
how to respond behave and
show the world what is possible thank
you
i um i wanted to
really uh continue my dad's legacy
and so i really appreciate the fact that
you
even took the time to to bring me in to
talk to me i mean
you're such a fantastic human being like
i have to tell you you really really
have a fan for life
thank you so much but it's all about you
maria and you're so awesome and thank
you for letting me introduce you thank
you so much
thank you everybody thank you i really
want to also just give a huge shout out
to sherwin williams because
we had so much fun taking that
personality test uh with the paints
you and myself and mikel all did it i
highly suggest that everybody goes
and does it it's really accurate we all
three got completely different
personalities
and i loved the results so thank you
to sherwin-williams for allowing us and
enabling us to get to do this
and you know people are always looking
for ways to refresh their homes and
go to the drewberrymore show.com and
share your story
and listen we might get to do a design
by drew with you
i would love it maria thank you
thank you thank you michael as well he
was amazing isn't he just the
best he is the funniest he is the
coolest and he's so talented and we
had such a wonderful time just being
thoughtful about the details
that you deserve so thank you maria
you